tenemos aquí el número 35 el 3 está en
el lugar de las decenas de escenas así
es que representa tres decenas o sea 30
que las tenemos dibujadas por aquí una
vez en dos grupos de diez y tres decenas
y luego el 5 está en el lugar de las
unidades rivales entonces representa 5
unidades y las tenemos por aquí 1 2 3 4
y 5 ahora lo que queremos hacer es tomar
este 35 y sumarle 6 este 6 está en el
lugar de las unidades y lo tenemos por
aquí 1 2 3 4 5 6 unidades y te voy a
pedir que le pongas pausa el vídeo y
hagas ese cálculo 35
bueno pues vamos a pensar en esto yo voy
a empezar por las unidades tenemos por
aquí cinco unidades y le queremos sumar
seis unidades eso a cuánto es igual esto
cuánto es si lo tomamos todo junto pues
cinco unidades más seis unidades son 11
unidades unidades claro que seguimos
teniendo por aquí estas tres decenas que
ahí tenemos por aquí tres decenas en
total tenemos tres decenas y 11 unidades
entonces pues podemos poner un más por
aquí tenemos tres decenas más 11
unidades ahora esto nos trae un gran
problema porque aquí tenemos 11 unidades
pero pues no podemos poner un número de
dos dígitos en el lugar de las unidades
lo que de hecho no podemos poner dos
dígitos en ninguna posición de valor ok
este número no lo puedo
escribir como 311 ok son tres decenas y
once unidades pero no lo puedo escribir
así nada más que entonces surge la
pregunta de cómo puedo escribir a este
número y eso nos lleva a cómo puedo
reagrupar esto de tal forma que nos
quede un número de un solo dígito por
aquí lo que tiene que ser un número que
sea 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 o 9 en lugar de un
número de dos dígitos como 11 que es un
1 y después otro 1 y bueno lo que
podemos hacer es reagrupar porque hay
porque mira tengo suficientes unidades
aquí como para crear un grupo de 10
podría yo llegar y tomar 10 de estas
unidades
con estas formar un grupo de 10 unidades
aunque hay formar una vez en monkey
tomamos estas 10 unidades las juntamos y
formamos un grupo de 10 con ellas y las
pasamos de este lado con el resto de las
decenas que más o menos se va a ver así
a ver repitiendo otra vez lo que
acabamos de hacer teníamos por aquí 11
unidades y 11 unidades son suficientes
para tomar 10 de estas unidades y formar
un grupo de 10 unidades o sea una decena
así es que agarramos estas 10 unidades y
las pasamos al lugar de las decenas en
la forma de una decena que hay aquí
están las 10 unidades pegaditas así es
que tenemos ahora pues con esta
reagrupación ahora tenemos uno dos tres
cuatro decenas cuatro decenas
cuántas unidades tenemos ahora pues
antes teníamos 11 unidades pero 10 de
ellas las reagrupamos y las pasamos del
lado de las decenas y entonces nos queda
simplemente una unidad por aquí y nos
queda una unidad así es que 3 decenas y
11 unidades es exactamente lo mismo que
cuatro decenas y una unidad y esto lo
podemos escribir por aquí porque tenemos
una unidad y cuatro decenas ahora cómo
podemos llegar a este resultado sin
tener que pasar por estos dibujitos ok
sin tener que dibujar estas cosas y
reagrupar de esta forma y todo aunque en
realidad esto es lo que tú deberías de
estar haciendo en tu cabeza y voy a
borrar esto
pero bueno para hacer esta suma
empezamos por las unidades tenemos 56 y
eso pues son 11 unidades pero no puedo
escribir aquí un 11 lo que hay entonces
lo que tienes que hacer en tu cabeza es
decir ok el 11 es una decena
y una unidad algunas veces nos enseñan
en la escuela que si tienes 56 eso es 11
y entonces pones 1 y llevamos 1 y así
pusimos el 11 de una forma un poco
extraña pero en el fondo lo que está
pasando es que estamos diciendo que 56
es una decena y una unidad y bueno de
hecho esta es una cosa muy curiosa
porque si ponemos por aquí el número 11
11 el número 11 tiene un 1 en el lugar
de las decenas y un 1 en el lugar de las
unidades entonces básicamente el 11 es
una decena y una unidad así es que como
56 es 11 es una decena y una unidad y
ahora ya nada más nos falta sumar las
decenas y una decena más tres decenas
cuatro decenas ahora realmente realmente
me interesa que entiendas qué es lo que
está pasando de fondo aquí porque
simplemente tomes y digas great 56 es 11
voy a escribir esto de una forma
chistosa pongo por aquí el 11 pero como
que dividido en dos pedazos no realmente
lo que está pasando de fondo es todo
este reagrupamiento ok que 11 unidades
son una vez n y una unidad estamos
reagrupando esas 10 unidades porque
tenemos por aquí 11 unidades
tomamos 10 de ellas para formar un grupo
de 10 unidades y ese es el uno ve por
aquí y nos queda una unidad por aquí
solita y ese es el uno ve por acá